all right welcome everybody
um I think we're sort of at a point
where it makes sense to issue a reminder
and go through the data that there is
still no actual evidence that the covet
vaccines approved in the United States
have caused even one death even a single
death and I had people yesterday sending
me uh links to The Joe Rogan Sanjay
Gupta interview I had links to articles
based on vayer's reporting and it just
is a good time to refresh what is
actually known about the vaccines now
this is not a segment about the Russian
vaccine this is not a segment about the
Chinese vaccine and what they have or
haven't done I just don't have data that
I can look at that I could say with any
um certitude that is reliable data I'm
not saying anything one way or the other
about those vaccines I just want to be
clear that if you're going to email me
things about the Russian vaccine I am
doing a segment here specifically about
the Pfizer vaccine
the moderna vaccine in the Johnson and
Johnson vaccines approved and available
here in the United States and on those
there is no clear evidence whatsoever
that they have caused any deaths in the
United States now this is different than
have any vaccinated people died of covid
last time two months ago I did a similar
segment with the data we had until then
and people wrote to me and said David
sir actually they didn't say Sir they
were less polite they said David you're
lying there are plenty of vaccinated
people that have died that's different
the the the question here is have the
vaccines caused deaths a couple of weeks
ago we had a very detailed report from
the CDC with the latest data on adverse
reactions to the vaccine now it's
important to remember just because
someone submitted a report of a death
caused by the vaccine to the veyers
system vaers doesn't mean that someone
actually died as a result of the vaccine
as the CDC reminds us and I encourage
you go through this article we're
linking to this a CDC page
Adverse Events described on this page
have been reported to the vayers system
theirs accepts reports of any adverse
event following vaccination that doesn't
even mean
related to the vaccination and we'll
talk about that in a second
um also remember that the FD I'm sorry
the yes the FDA requires that Health
Care Providers report deaths that take
place after covet vaccination
even if the health care provider has no
real reason to think that the death is
related to the vaccine it's just it
happened after the vaccine sometimes
people die weeks after the vaccine has
nothing to do even with covid never mind
the vaccine it's still supposed to be
reported and then evaluated and again
anybody can submit such a report as it
says here reports of Adverse Events to
vayers following vaccination including
deaths do not necessarily mean that a
vaccine caused a health problem
so what has the CDC put out and this is
the their latest report it's a couple
weeks old now about vaccine reactions
and Adverse Events it's a matter of
reading through these one by one and
understanding them first
anaphylaxis after covid-19 vaccination
it's rare it's occurred in two to five
out of every million vaccinated people
in the United States severe allergic
reactions including anaphylaxis can
occur after any vaccination if it occurs
vaccination providers can effectively
and immediately treat the reaction
that's not unique to the covid vaccine
uh and it is extraordinarily rare and
treatable okay
thrombosis with thrombocytopenia
syndrome after the jnj vaccine is rare
as of October 6th about eight days ago
more than 15 million doses of the jnj
vaccine were given there have been 47
reports of people who got the vaccine
and later developed TTS thrombosis with
thrombocytopenia syndrome
concentrated among women under 50 years
old
okay to date two confirmed cases of TTS
have been reported with moderna after
382 million doses so extraordinarily
rare we then have as has been the case
with other vaccines in the past GBS
Guillain-Barre syndrome and people who
got jnj
uh very rare disorder 15 million jnj
vaccines administered 228 preliminary
reports and those have to be looked at
more closely
typically men over 50. so we talked
about TTS very rare concentrated in
women under 50 with the jnj GBS very
rare concentrated in men over 50.
um with the jnj we then heard of
myocarditis and pericarditis after
covid-19 very rare
um 1640 reports inveyors and again
remember anybody can submit that and
there's no question there's a bandwagon
effect if people submitting submitting
submitting you should look at what's
been submitted to theirs 1640 submitted
among people under 30.
most cases reported particularly in
adolescent males and young adults
through follow-up including medical
records review the CDC and FDA have
confirmed about half 926 reports and uh
the relationship to uh vaccination is
still being investigated and then
reports of deaths this is a really
important thing because theyers has
received 8600 reports of deaths but even
linking them causally to the vaccine is
not something that has been done yet
when you give hundreds of millions of
people a vaccine by sheer Actuarial
reality the fact that people die people
are going to die in the days weeks and
months after receiving a vaccine that's
supposed to be reported to vayers even
if it's not believed to be because of
the vaccine and there is every reason to
believe there are lots of false reports
but it is really important that we go by
what the CDC has assessed based on the
data now what about blood clots that's
another one that we've been hearing a
little bit about
researchers are still looking at whether
there's any connection between J and J
and a rare type of blood clot uh very
very few cases still being investigated
and once we have something more
definitive on that we will talk about it
so when you hear the talking point is
basically look at all of the deaths that
have been reported people talk about
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of deaths due to the vaccine the actual
number of deaths reported to the system
is 8 600. and
um there has been no confirmation that
it is because of the vaccine they are
deaths that took place after individuals
were vaccinated that's the data I have
no interest in hiding or exaggerating or
downplaying anything that is the data as
we know it right now and with time we
will continue to get updated reports
one of our sponsors is Magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals I loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb great if you're just
trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon They're bringing
back cookies and cream They're bringing
back Maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as I do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com Pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code Pacman at checkout